[Musik]
Sonntagmittag 12 Uhr ich begrüße Sie
herzlich zum internationalen
Frühschoppen live aus Köln ja das war
ein deutliches Zeichen für Kiev aus
Brüssel in dieser Woche 50 Milliarden
Euro Hilfe für den Haushalt der Ukraine
sagt Europa zu Ungarn hat seine Blockade
aufgegeben die EU steht also fest an der
Seite der Ukraine wie lange werden die
USA das noch tun die Mittel für den
Krieg gegen Russland sind schon Teil des
us-wahlkampfs und werden zurzeit
blockiert die Lage an der Front in der
Ukraine wird immer dramatischer fast
zwei Jahre nach Kriegsbeginn fehlt es an
Ausrüstung Munition und Soldaten und
Zeichen für Verhandlungen oder eine
diplomatische Lösung gibt es genauso
wenig Ukraine Russland und der Westen
wie weit ist der Weg zum Frieden darüber
sprechen wir heute Mittag und ich freue
mich sehr über diese Gäste herzlich
willkommen lutmiller mellnik Ukrainerin
wissenschaftliche Mitarbeiterin des
Instituts für europäische Politik und
Moderatorin des Podcast Ukraine Memo ich
begrüße Sora sahadi Nelson sie ist
US-amerikanische Journalistin und
Moderatorin des Podcasts commonround
Berlin herzlich willkommen Thomas
gutschker Brüssel Korrespondent der
Frankfurter Allgemeinen Zeitung und bei
uns ist Andreas zumach freier Journalist
und Publizist er war langjähriger
un-korrespondent für die Tageszeitung
Tatz fr Melnik jetzt gibt es
Erleichterung wenn man auf die Seite der
EU schaut für die Ukraine die Milliarden
Hilfen sind Z gesagt trotzdem wie ist
die Lage im Moment in der Ukraine wie
stark ist die Hoffnung dass man diesen
Krieg noch gewinnen kann m das war in
der Tat sehr wichtig jetzt für die
Ukraine die Unterstützung von 50
Milliarden Euro zu bekommen aber man
muss auch nicht verstehen dass
der der Defizit des ukrainischen Budgets
so ca nur für dieses Jahr so ca 40
Milliarden Euro beträgt das heißt diese
finanzielle Hilfe das ist nicht alles
und man muss für die Zukunft weiterhin
Finanzspritzen für die Ukraine vor
vorbereiten ich glaube in den letzten
zwei Jahren was wir jetzt gesehen haben
und das ist gar keine Überraschung die
Menschen sind müde dazu kommt dass
Russland diesen Krieg nicht nur mit
Waffen führt sondern wirklich
psychologischen Terror betreibt wir
wissen dass seit nur dem seit zwei
Monaten mehr als 300 Raketen
abgeschossen wurden 600 drohen
abgeschossen wurden auf die Ukraine was
jetzt zusätzlich kommt und was ich von
meinen Verwandten aber auch von
verschiedenen Kollegen aus der Ukraine
wahrnehme dass man
ständig Informationen bekommt dass die
Schulen vermindt sind das heißt die
Kinder können nicht ruhig in die Schulen
gehen obwohl die Infrastruktur da ist
aber ständig diese Telefonate die Schule
ist vermindt und man merkt also diese
psychologische Teror nimmt eigentlich zu
was dagegen hilft ja dann auch keine
Militärhilfe die aber immer noch
gefordert wird auch und ich glaube was
vielleicht was man auch festgestellt hat
Militär ische Hilfe und überhaupt die
Waffen das ist die einzige Möglichkeit
für die Ukrainer ihre Existenz zu
sichern wenn man so ein Nachbar hat wie
Russland Herr gutschka es war ein Gipfel
wo manche sagen so eine Art ja ein
historischer Gipfel sogar der ganz
schnell zu Ende ging weil Ungarn seine
Blockade aufgegeben hat ist damit jetzt
so ein klares Zeichen die Europäische
Union wird auch auf die Dauer wirklich
immer an der Seite der Ukraine stehen
also das Wort immer ist natürlich ein
großes Wort aber auf die Dauer das
glaube ich kann man schon unterstreichen
jedenfalls äh für die nächsten zwei
Jahre
ähm es war ein Moment der Wahrheit das
muss man ganz klar sagen Viktor Orban
hat ja großen Druck
versucht zu entfalten eine
erpressungsstrategie durchzusetzen äh
und er ist damit gescheitert der hat
nichts im Gegenzug bekommen anders als
noch im Dezember wo er ja der Eröffnung
von Erweiterungsverhandlungen zugestimmt
hat und die Kommission dann nahezu
zeitgleich 10 Milliarden Euro aus
kohäionsmitteln freigegeben hat es
streitet zwar dass das ein ursächlichen
Zusammenhang hat aber zumindest das
zeitliche Zusammentreffen war doch sehr
auffällig so jetzt kann man nach vorne
blicken sind zwei zentrale
Entscheidungen getroffen zu den
Erweiterungsverhandlungen und zur
weiteren finanziellen Unterstützung und
es gibt noch ein drittes die EUStaaten
sind auch bereit mehr Geld für die
Verteidigung der Ukraine auszugeben für
Waffen Lieferungen auch da gab es eine
große Zögerlichkeit in den letzten
Wochen und Monaten es gab eine
Ernüchterung und eine Müdigkeit und ich
glaube die Ernüchterung ist immer noch
da was die Kriegsziele angeht aber die
Müdigkeit und damit auch die irosion der
Unterstützung das haben wir jetzt
überwundenm und das muss man natürlich
auch überwinden wenn
man auf die USA schaut Frau Nelson und
da sieht dass da die Unterstützung für
die Ukraine ja nun schwindet und noch
immer dies Hilfspaket auch auch
blockiert ist also wie sehr stehen die
USA noch an der Seite der Ukraine ja
also die stehen an der Seite der Ukraine
aber nicht mit so eine Mehrheit wie man
am Anfang gehabt hat und man muss ich
glaube das wichtigste was dieses Jahr
passiert ist ist dass Herr beiden jetzt
seine Wörter geändert hat also der sagt
die USA wird sol lang wie es möglich ist
und wie lange solange wie es kann
Ukraine unterstützen statt dass bis also
solange wie dieser Krieg braucht also
das deswegen äh ist da eine Idee die
jetzt ich glaube dass dass Herr zelinski
wird von Herr beiden hören dass er
vielleicht ein Teilsieg akzeptieren soll
und das heißt am Ende dass also das ist
wegen dem
Wahlkampf dieser chaotischer Wahlkampf
den wir jetzt dieses Jahr haben also ich
ich würde staunen wenn Herr Biden das
nicht irgendwann mit Herr selinski
erwähnen würde in 2024 okay darüber
sprechen wir natürlich gleich noch
ausführlich her zumach zumach
entschuldigung es wächst ja die Sorge
dass es ja so ein ja ein stellungs Krieg
bleibt im Moment ist es ja schwierig
wenn man die Lage an der Front sieht
dass es da nicht wirklich vorangeht also
wo sehen sie Möglichkeiten des
Westens wirklich Einfluss zu zu nehmen
auf diesen Krieg noch also ich sehe das
grundsätzlich anders ein bisschen mehr
noch in die Richtung von Kollegin Nelson
je länger die Nato und EU-Staaten
gemeinen als der Westen bezeichnet an
der Illusion festhalten dass die Ukraine
diesen gegen sie geführten Krieg
gewinnen kann desto größer wird die
Gefahr dass es auf eine Teilung des
Landes hinausläuft mit Billigung der
beiden Administration also
möglicherweise noch bevor einem
eventuellen Wahlsieg von Donald Trump im
November weil das Thema im US-Wahlkampf
immer wichtiger wird und wenn die beiden
Administration die Demokratische Partei
irgendwann im Frühsommer zu der
Wahrnehmung kommt wir verlieren die
Wahlen möglicherweise über dieses Thema
wird möglicherweise die beiden
Administration Herrn Putin territoriale
Konzession signalisieren nach dem Motto
die Krim oder vielleicht auch Teile des
dombas kannst du behalten das werden wir
Herrn selenski schon beibiegen und das
wäre das fatalste Ergebnis dieses
Krieges einmal für die betroffene
ukrainische Zivilbevölkerung in den dann
russischen Territorien aber auch als
Signal in den Rest der Welt vor allem da
wo es auch territoriale Konflikte gibt
das Signal wäre dann die Anwendung
militärischer Gewalt zur Veränderung von
Grenzen funktioniert Frau Mel zum das
ist eine Illusion diesen Krieg noch zu
gewinnen wie Sie sehen Sie das wissen
Sie wir sprechen seit zwei Jahren
darüber das ist nichts Neues und ich
habe das Gefühl das ist so wie eine
Mantra dass man immer sagt die Ukraine
die Ukrainer werden jetzt nicht gewinnen
irgendwie sagt man nicht Russland wird
verlieren und ich weiß nicht woher das
kommt das eine Sache und mit selenski
ich glaube es gibt eine großer Irrtum
mit Blick dass man sagt mit zelenski
wird man verhandeln selenski ist nur der
Präsident der Ukraine der entscheidet
nicht alles der kommuniziert das was die
ukrainische Bevölkerung will so man kann
ihn als Kommunikator nennen aber sehr
häufig wird er so dargestellt als ob er
allmächtige ist und alles im Griff hat
und wird alles entscheiden das das das
stimmt nicht wir hatten z.B in der
Ukraine noch 2015 als poroschenko an der
Macht war da gab es auf den Druck des
zestens
sozusagen der Versuch die ukrainische
Verfassung zu ändern boroschenko wollte
das auf den Druck sozusagen zu machen
und was wir am Ende hatten dass es große
Proteste gab und vier Personen
gestorben sind als das ukrainische
Parlament versucht überhaupt das Gesetz
zu ändern und irgendwie die Verfassung
zu ändern das heißt wenn jetzt in der
Ukraine sowas kommt D selenski sagt wir
sollen irgendwie auf diese Territorien
verzichten werden wir ganz schlimme
Probleme sozusagen in der Bevölkerung
haben die Bevölkerung und die
ukrainische Gesellschaft wird das nicht
akzeptieren und der andere vielleicht
Moment was was ich persönlich sehe ich
bin
keine Experten für die Militär aber
sogar ich kann wahrnehmen dass die
Ukraine jetzt ihre ihr Potenzial
vergrößert was die
Waffen Produktion angeht und was wir
auch sehen dass der Krieg heute anders
funktioniert Hochtechnologien sind sehr
wichtig man spricht die ganze Zeit über
die drohen und man muss jetzt alles tun
um sozusagen die Ukraine in die Lage zu
versetzen all diese Technologien zu
bekommen und ich habe das Gefühl wir
haben immer den Krieg so da vorgestellt
als ob wir noch im Zweiten Weltkrieg
sozusagen aber es fehlt doch ganz klar
an Munition da gab's ja auch die die
Idee dass Europa mehr Munition liefert
das FK wird jetzt auch nicht so
funktionieren Herr gutschka ist es wie
her zumach sagt eine Illusion dass die
Ukrainer diesen Krieg gewinnen
m jetzt muss man erstmal definieren was
gewinnen heißt also wenn gewinnen heißt
dass sie ihr gesamtes Territorium zurück
erobern kann mit militärischer Macht
dann würde ich auch sagen das ist eine
Illusion wenn gewinnen heißt dass es ihr
gelingt den russischen Angriffswillen zu
brechen und es die Kosten für Russland
einer Besatzung äh insbesondere im Süden
der Ukraine so hoch zutreiben dass auch
für Russland hier kein erkennbarer
Gewinn mehr möglich ist dann hat sie
schon viel erreicht also gewinnen äh äh
kann man unterschiedlich definieren das
ist die die erste Differenzierung die
ich machen würde das zweite was die
Waffenlieferung angeht das stimmt die
Europäer haben sehr lange gebraucht bis
sie in die pushchen gekommen sind äh man
kann das an der Artilleriemunition
erkennen da gab es das Ziel eine
Millionen Granaten innerhalb eines
Jahres zu liefern Stichtag im März da
gab es einen offenbarungseit diese Woche
der uns dann nicht mehr überrascht hat
das wird nicht möglich sein aber die
zweite Botschaft die ist auch wichtig
die Industrie hat ihre Kapazitäten
hochgefahren und äh es gibt gesicherte
Bestellungen
die der Ukraine bis Ende des Jahres
600.000 neue Granaten schwere Granaten
zu sichern und und liefern werden und
das bedeutet umgerechnet die hat jetzt
ungefähr 2000 Granaten am Tag russland
hat fünfm so viel mit diesen Lieferungen
äh von der Industrie wird die Ukraine
ihren täglichen ähm täglichen täglich
verfügbare Granaten verdoppeln können
von 2000 auf 4000 und das ist eine
wesentliche Verbesserung auf dem
Schlachtfeld also und das würde der
Ukraine dann doch helfen aber also ich
würde gerne auf die Frage die Frau
Melnik mir gestellt hat nach meinem
ersten Statement Antworten wieso
Illusion
die Regierung zelenski und ich bin
völlig mit ihnen einer Meinung das
spricht er nicht alleine sondern für die
Regierung und für zumindest weite Teil
des Volkes hat das Ziel dieses Krieges
per regierungsdekret festgelegt und das
offizielle Ziel hat der gutschka eben
genannt ist die vollständige
Rückeroberung aller von Russland
eroberten und besetzten Territorien
inklusive der völkerrechtswiedrig
besetzten Krim und gemessen an diesem
Ziel hat die Regierung selenski in den
letzten 15 Monaten ihre Erwartungen
Hoffnungen Forderung an militärische
Unterstützung definiert mit ganz klaren
Zahlen von Panzern von Drohnen von
Luftwaffe ich will das jetzt aus
Zeitgründen nicht alles aufzählen das
ist völlig unrealistisch wenn man sich
die Zahlen wirklich vor Augen hält
selbst wenn die Ukraine all das bekäme
ist dann immer noch die Frage ob sie
dieses von ihr definierte militärische
Ziel durchsetzen kann und der
Oberbefehlshaber der ukrainischen
Streitkräfte Valerie saluschnin hat ja
nun zuerst am ersten November im
britischen Economist und jetzt wieder
vor zwei Tagen in einem großen Essay in
der amerikanischen Fernsehanstalt CNN
sehr klar gemacht wo die Defizite liegen
er hat jetzt neu hinzugefügt auch die
Frage der Mobilisierung von Truppen die
immer schwieriger wird das meine ich mit
Illusion und damit wir uns nicht
missverständen ich habe nicht dafür
plädiert dass man territoriale
Konzession macht und dass die
innenpolitisch kaum durchsetzbar werden
sehe ich genauso ich habe nur davor
gewarnt wenn es so weiter geht wie
bisher und es nicht zu einem
Waffenstillstand und Verhandlungen kommt
über die wir gleich noch reden müssen
wird das Szenario passieren was ich
erläutert habe und was Frau Nelson
angedeutet hat dass die amerikanische
Regierung aus innenpolitischen
machterhaltungsgründen mit Blick auf den
November einen Schwenk macht und dann
tatsächlich die territorialen
Konzessionen mit Putin vereinbart über
den Kopf der Ukraine wie sehr kann man
das
bewerkstellung also wie wie gefährlich
wäre das wenn wenn die USA sagen würden
wir wollen jetzt verhandeln über
letztendlich den Willen der Ukraine
hinweg so klingt es ja eigentlich na ja
ich sag so
ähm solange die Ukrainer kämpft sind wir
nicht dran würde die Ukrainer auf hören
zu kämpfen werden wir dran und die
Europäer müssen halt das begreifen sie
sitzen heute nicht in den greäbern aber
das ist jetzt die Entscheidung entweder
helfen wir und unterstützen wir die
Ukraine damit sowas wir hier nicht
erleben oder wir warten und schauen
selber werden uns verteidigen und ich
muss vielleicht auch betonen die
Ukrainer haben auch nicht geglaubt dass
Russland es angreifen
wird ja wir die waren auch nicht so
richtig vorbereitet es gab schon diesen
Krieg 2000 begohen 2014 aber bis zum
letzten sozusagen bis zum großen Krieg
wie das jetzt in der Ukraine genannt
wird hat man wirklich nicht geglaubt und
ich frage mich woher kommt diese
Zuversicht insbesondere auch in
Deutschland dass man denkte ja das wir
werden hier weiterhin unsere Ruhe
sozusagen unseren Frieden haben woher
kommt das ja also ich würde gerne eine
Bemerkung noch machen also es gab eine
Phase äh im Spätherbst letzten Jahres äh
wo ich auch den Eindruck habe hatte dass
jetzt Druck aufgebaut wird auf die
Ukraine an den Verhandlungstisch
zurückzukehren und das ganz klare Indiz
dafür war dass
es keine neuen Zusagen gab weder
finanzieller noch militärischer Art
nicht nur aus Amerika nicht sondern auch
auch von den Europäern so jetzt muss man
aber auch mal feststellen diese
Situation hat sich geändertm wir leben
jetzt Anfang
2024 in einer Situation die für die
Ukraine schon deutlich besser ist als
sie noch vor zwei Monaten war was diese
Zusagen angeht und was hat dazu geführt
warum ist dieser Wandel gekommen aus
meiner Sicht lag das ganz klar daran
dass die Europäer erkannt haben welches
Risiko in Washington schlummert und dass
es nicht so ist dass wir erst warten
müssen bis zur
Präsidentenwahl welche Entscheidung dort
trifft sondern dass womöglich der
Kongress bis dahin blockiert bleibt und
Europa selbst deutlich mehr
Verantwortung übernehmen muss das das
halte ich für eine wesentliche
Entwicklung da ist Europa auch ein Stück
weit aufgewacht aufgewacht ja Frau
Nelsen wie sehr wie stark sind die
Erwartungen der USA dass die Europäer ja
selber ihre Verteidigung stärker in die
Hand nehmen ich würde sehr sagen sehr
hoch egal ob Republikaner oder
Demokraten alle sind damit einverstanden
natürlich jetzt ist da so ein Rennen
weil wir vor November muss alles
erledigt werden und da ist auch eine
Müdigkeit mit Krieg und bisher hat
beiden nicht große Gewinne wenn es zu
Kriege kommt ich meine Ukraine ist nicht
ein Gewinn Afghanistan war bestimmt kein
Gewinn für ihn und alle hat vergessen
dass es war Trump der das alle
angefangen hat aber das das liegt jetzt
alles also das ist alles beiden seine
Schuld und jetzt haben wir auch noch den
Krieg im Nahen Osten wir haben überhaupt
nicht darüber geredet und das ist jetzt
für Amerikaner viel wichtiger als was in
Europa vorgeht und ja die die Meinung
ist Europa gut dass Europa jetzt 50
Milliarden Euro an Ukraine versendet
aber das sind ja Finanzhilfen das ist
jetzt nicht eine klare militärische
hilicht mal wichtig aber ich glaube
Ukraine weiß also die Regierung Ukraine
weiß auch sie können sich nicht auf
Amerika verlassen wenn es wenigstens vor
november und wenn Trump jetzt wieder
Präsident wenn dann überhaupt nicht mehr
dann ist die NATO auch in Gefahr und
also ich würde gerne noch gutchka die
Schilderung zum letzten Jahr da fehlt
natürlich ein wichtiges Mosaikstein sie
haben es so formuliert das sei Druck
aufgearbeitet gemacht worden ich
erinnere das ein bisschen anders ich
erinnere dass ab Januar letzten Jahres
die große Frühjahrsoffensive angekündigt
wird die dann Mitte Juni erst begonnen
hat und in allen westien Hauptstädten
USA wie bei uns ist diese
frühahrsinitiative die verspätete mit
der Zielsetzung und der Hoffnung
verbunden worden dass bis zum Herbst
letzten Jahres die ukrainischen
schitkräfte wenigstens so viel
Fortschritte machen auf dem Schlachtfeld
dass sie dann in einer besseren Position
sind für einen Verhandlungstisch zu den
man sie dann bringen will das hat sich
allusionen erwiesen und ich muss sagen
so so gewaltig die Zahl 50 Milliarden
Wirtschaftshilfe jetzt klingt mit Blick
auf das was ich vorhin beschrieben habe
Diskrepanz der für notwendig erklärten
Militärhilfe durch die ukrainische
Regierung und dem was tatsächlich
zugesagt ist tatsächlich und auch mit
Verspätung geliefert wird helfen diese
50 Milliarden nicht also ich bleibe bei
dieser Illusion und erlauben Sie mir
noch einen Satz V melding also ich hoffe
dass die Historiker irgendwann mal alle
Fakten ans Licht bringen aber die
Behauptung dass die ukrainische
Regierung od zumindest Herr selenski
nicht wussten was auf sie zukommt da
gibt's ja viele Fragezeichen er hat am
19 Februar auf der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz 22 war im Raum
gesagt wir haben keine Anzeichen für
einen bevorstehenden russischen Krieg
keine histor er hat die Empfehlung aller
seiner Gesprächspartner darunter Scholz
ins Exil zu gehen als defettismus
zurückgewiesen er hat dann in einem
Interview mit der Washington Post im
Oktober 22 erklärt ich wusste mit
Sicherheit dass Russland angreift seit
Oktober
21 habe es völlig geheim gehalten aus
zwei Gründen weil ich Angst hatte wenn
es bekannt wird gehen hertausende Männer
im sogenannten whrfähigen Alter ins
Ausland und zweitens wir erleben einen
Wirtschaftseinbruch mit mindestens 7
Milliarden Dollar pro Monat das da sind
Widersprüche ich will nur drauf
hinweisen ich hoffe dass das irgendwann
geklärt wird aber so einfach wie sie es
da gestellt haben ist es offensichtlich
nicht in der Ukraine wird auch das
diskutiert dass das andere Politiker
sozusagen das lauter gesagt haben ja wir
sollen uns vorbereiten wir sollen schon
die Gräber sozusagen all diese
Fortifikation aufbauen und so weiter und
ja die schützengriber aber und solens
hat in der Tat versucht diese diese
Stimmung er hat daran nicht geglaubt und
man muss auch nicht vergessen als er
Präsident wurde war auch sein Motto wenn
ich Präsident werde wird dieser Krieg zu
Ende sein der seit 2014 da ist aber das
ist nicht nur zelenski der sozusagen
daran geglaubt hat ich frage mich wo war
der Westen wenn der Westen so gut mit
seinen Technologien und Satelliten da
ist warum hat man vorher all diese
munitionswerken nicht sozusagen
aufgebaut und und das war aber war aber
zu spät man hat der Ukraine nur drei
Tage gegeben ja man hat gewartet dre
Tage
versuch es hilft jetzt natürlich nicht
uns nicht wirklich weiter äh über diese
Zeit zu streiten auch wenn das sicher
wichtig ist das aufzuarbeiten aber
letztlich muss der Blick ja nach vorne
gehen und wenn man nach vorne blickt
dann ist es zwar so dass auf dem
Schlachtfeld in der Tat ein Pad herrscht
und es auch sehr unwahrscheinlich ist
dass sich daran im Lauf des Jahres etw
was zugunsten der Ukraine verbessert
im Gegenteil es ist wichtig der Ukraine
zu helfen um diesen Zustand zu erhalten
und deswegen bin ich da mit ihnen auch
nicht einverstanden wenn sie sagen es
gibt diese Illusion man könnne den Krieg
gewinnen ich glaube diese Illusion gibt
es spätestens seit dem vergangenen
Herbst nicht
mehr sondern man muss sich jetzt auf
eine neue Situation einstellen und ver
hern dass Russland hier weiter terr
gewinnt aber es gibt auch einen Erfolg
und das darf man nicht ganz unter den
Tisch fallen lassen weil es
wirtschaftlich wichtig ist die Ukraine
hat es geschafft ohne eigene Marine
Russland aus dem Schwarzen Meer zu
verdrängen und ist jetzt in der Lage
tatsächlich wieder Güter zu importieren
und zu exportieren fast auf dem Niveau
wie vor dem Krieg und das hat gewaltige
Folgen ich glaube es ungefähr 5% des
Bruttosozialprodukts die das Land auf
diese Weise erwirtschaftet und das ist
ein ischer
Erfolg wie sehr spielt die die Tatsache
eine Rolle dass man jetzt immer davon
spricht dass Ukraine das nicht gewinnen
kann dass Russland vielleicht viel
stärker ist ist das auch Teil der
Desinformation ich finde schon ich finde
sogar die Desinformation begann
eigentlich 2014 und 2015 mit dem
euromeidan und das wurde nicht
aufgearbeitet damals war das Ziele
Russland immer zu zeigen die Ukraine ist
ein failed state und dementsprechend hat
man so eine gepuscht wie die Ukraine ist
korrupt chaotisch gelenkt von außen und
das war auch in den russischen Medien zu
sehen das war auch in den deutschen
Medien zu sehen dass man vieles
übernommen hat was ich sehr faszinierend
sage ich so finde und ein bisschen so
schockierend dass nach dem großen Krieg
seit zi Jahren hat man auf bestimmte
narrative verzichtet und jetzt plötzlich
sind diese narrative wieder da z.B dass
man anfängt über Rechtsradikalismus zu
sprechen über ein krup des Land obwohl
die Ukraine sogar im Krieg große
Fortschritte macht und die Frage warum
fangen wir jetzt darüber zu zu sprechen
wollen wir sagen weil dieses Land noch
nicht so genug demokratisch ist brauchen
wir sie nicht zu unterstützen und ich
gehe davon aus dass ist das Ziel von
Putin einfach zu zeigen es lohnt sich
nicht in die die Ukraine zu unterstützen
und unser Geld in die Ukraine zu
investieren und da müssen wir sozusagen
mehr Gedanken machen wie wir damit mit
diesem Desinformation umgehen können und
da sehe ich noch nicht aber
Entschuldigung Frau melniik das sind
zwei pa verschiedene Schuhe eine
realistische nüchterne Einschätzung der
militärischen Kräfteverhältnis und ich
gebe ih dem Punkt Recht auch hier gibt's
einen noch zu klärenen Widerspruch die
amerikanische Regierung hat seit der 1
Januar Woche 22 in fast täglichen
Pressekonferenzen weltöffentlich ihre
tatsächlichen oder wie viele vielleicht
dachten vermeintlichen
Geheimdiensterkenntnisse kundgan
Russland wird angreifen Außenminister
blinken hat uns in hintergrunden
Gesprächen genau erzählt wie es losgehen
wird es stimmte alles bis auf das Datum
16 januar in der ganzen Zeit sagt die
Regierung selenski wir haben keine
Anzeichen dann hat man sich getäuscht in
den Fähigkeiten man hat selensk ja
deswegen zum Exil aufgefordert weil man
die Einschätzung hatte wenn Russland
tatsächlich angreift hat die Ukraine
keine Chance in den ersten drei
Kriegswochen hat man festgestellt dass
das ein Irtum war aber dann gab es die
rückeroberungserfolge im September
Oktober 2 die die Hoffnung die Ukraine
könne diesen Krieg auch gesamthaft
militärisch gewinnen wieder verstärkt
hat aber wir hören seit November 22 von
führenden oder damals führenden
westlichen Militärs darunter der
inzwischen pensionierte amerikanische
oberbefehlsh haber dass dieser Krieg
nicht zu gewinnen ist und nur am
verhandlungsicht zu beenden ist das ist
was anderes als die von Ihnen
beschriebenen narrative ich widerspreche
auch jedem der mit Hinweis auf
Korruption oder rechte Kräfte sagt
deswegen ist die Ukraine nicht zu
verteidigen natürlich selbst wenn Sie
eine faschistische Diktatur ist was sie
nicht wäre ist das kein aller
Rechtfertigung für den russischen
Angriffskrieg und verdient die Ukraine
unsere Unterstützung meine Frage geht
hin in die Richtung ob es realistisch
ist und Herr Herr Kutch das Ziel ist ja
sogar bis heute von Herrn zelenski in
allen vier Konferenzen die stattgefunden
haben in dem Friedensplan formuliert ven
und zwar sogar als Vorbedingung das
steht ja in dem Fried drin Vorbedingung
Verhandlung er alle nur nur ein Satz
dazu wir könnten über den Friedensplan
reden machen wir vielleicht auch noch
das ist auch sehr interessant aber Herr
selenski hat immer wieder gesagt dass
die Ukraine ihre territoriale Integrität
wahren wird dass das aber nicht zwingend
auf militärischenem Weg erfolgen muss
das hat er gerade gesagt gegenüber
einwenden ob er denn die Krim
zurückerobern könnte ich würde würd gern
eben noch mal nach vorne schauen der
ehemalige ukrainische Botschafter in
Deutschland der auch Melnik heißt aber
nicht mit ihnen irgendwie verwandt ist
weil Melnik eentlich Müller heißt auf
Ukraine und viele Menschen dort so
heißen er hat gesagt eine er hat gesagt
man muss jetzt eine strategische
diplomatische Initiative versuchen um um
Putin herauszufordern und dann auch den
globalen Süden starker einzubinden und
er sagt man muss die Großmächte auch
Deutschland auffordern äh nicht
abzuwarten eben bis die wie die große
Schlacht ausgeht sondern selbst aktiv zu
werden Frau M wenn Sie das Hören ist es
nicht wichtig jetzt wo die Ukraine noch
stark noch sagen mal wo es noch ein Pat
gibt zu sagen okay wir müssen das jetzt
versuchen
m ich glaube es gibt schon sage ich so
die der Ruf Deutschlands hat sich auch
verbessert auch wenn man mit der
ukrainischen expertinen spricht auch mit
einfachen Ukrainerinnen
Deutschland genießt jetzt einen guten
Ruf und gilt auch als Unterstützer was
allerdings immer sozusagen gefragt wird
macht Deutschland alles um die Ukrain zu
helfen ist das das Potenzial das
sozusagen Deutschland hat und ich glaube
an dieser Stelle muss Deutschland viel
viel mehr machen was mich in Deutschland
stört ich glaube wir diskutieren über
verschiedene Waffen Systeme es geht
jetzt um die Frage der Diplomatie der
die kann Deutschland irgendwie eine
aktivere Rolle spielen um irgendwo in
irgendetwas mit Richtung ich finde das
noch nicht weil wir noch nicht die
militärischen sozusagen Potenziale
ausgeschöpft haben die Militärflugzeuge
sind noch da nicht alle Raketen sind
noch da und wer weiß was wir noch hier
im Lager haben und irgendwann beginnen
wir auch über verschiedene
Waffengattungen zu sprechen aber
vielleicht später aber ist es noch nicht
an der Zeit die die Ukraine muss in eine
Position der Stärke kommen ich glaube
das das ist klar die jetzige Situation
ist ja doch so dass die Initiative nicht
mehr bei der Ukraine liegt diese
Gegenoffensive hat sich erschöpft in der
Tat war sie ziemlich er folglos äh und
Russland äh gewinnt an einzelnen Fronten
äh lokale Schlachten
ähm äh und das ist auch eine bedrohliche
Situation deswegen muss der Westen
weiterhelfen aber in dieser Situation wo
Russland die Initiative hat sollten wir
nicht erwarten dass äh irgendwelche
Verhandlungen zugunsten äh der Ukraine
geführt werden könnten das wäre eine
Illusion also es muss ein eine ein
Wandel eintreten im Schwarzen Meer ist
da schon ein es passiert aber solange
die Russen so eingegraben sind und so
sich so festgesetzt haben gerade im
Süden der Ukraine sehe ich nicht warum
sie ohne
irgendwelche Vorbedingungen an den Tisch
kommen würden Donald Trump Frau Nelsen
sagt ja wenn ich Präsident bin ich werde
diesen Krieg innerhalb von 24 Stunden
beenden ist das ein also wie ist da sein
Argument und ist das etwas was ernst
genommen wird äh also es wird ernst
genommen von die die viele Leute die ihn
unterstützen aber nein nicht von die
Experten nicht von die vom Militär oder
sowas ich meine weil er nicht erklärt
wie er das schaffen würde das der macht
ja immer diese Sprüche und so aber man
muss wahrnehmen dass dieser Mann zurzeit
in die Umfragen von ganz USA dass er
vorliegt also dass beiden hinter ihm
fünf Punkte sind nur mal fünf Punkte das
und wir haben wie gesagt wir wir reden
überhaupt nicht über den nahen
ostenkrieg da ist ein großer Krieg der
zurzeit sehr also für Amerika sehr
wichtig ist und wo auch viele von beiden
von seine Unterstützer die progressiven
die jungen jüngeren Menschen die
schwarzen die gehen alle langsam weg die
die sagen wir sitzen diese Wahl aus
obwohl Trump dann also zurückkommt und
man man muss überlegen was passiert
nicht nur mit Ukraine aber mit NATO mit
Europa wenn Trump zurückkommt der hat
schon klar gemacht dass dass er
vielleicht sogar Amerika aus NATO
rauszieht ob das wirklich kommt oder
nicht ist ich meine die die Bedrohung
ist genug da muss man wirklich drüber
denken und nicht nur über ob
Ukraine ob man hier die gegen Offensive
die die ist
klar hat das nicht geklappt wie alle das
wenigstens von die ukrainische Seite und
die um Westen das das gerne gehofft
haben aber man muss auch denken was
passiert jetzt in November in Amerika
und das aber auch sogar wenn beiden
gewinnen würde scheint ja jetzt auf ein
Rennen beiden Trump hinauszulaufen
beiden hat jetzt die Vorwahlen auch in
souus Carolina gewonnen also auch da
muss sich ja Europa stärker sozusagen
aufrüsten und stärker auf seine eigene
verteig hoffen dass was in 20 2020
passiert ist noch mal passiert also für
die Leute die gegen Trump sind aber das
Problem ist dass da ist wie soll ich
sagen beiden fatig auf Englisch ist
Müdigkeit und der hat nicht die diese
also Ukraine hilft nicht in also
Außenpolitik ist sowieso nicht
wichtigämpfer und und Ukraine bestimmt
nicht zurzeit Herr zumach wie sehr muss
sich die muss ich Europa auf seine
eigenen Kräfte stützen uns auch Europa
seine eigene verteidigungspolitische
Strategie ja überdenken und einfach ganz
banal gesagt aufrüsten also ich sehe die
Gefährdung nicht so sehr wie sie
beschrieben wird wenn Trump diesen
Wahlkampf gewinnt auch mit Hilfe des der
Auseinandersetzung über Ukraine dann
nicht weil die Leute ihm zutrauen
innerhalb von 24 Stunden ein Abkommen
zum Beendung dieses Krieges
durchzusetzen oder weil er eine bessere
außenpolitische Analyse hat so allein
deswegen weil das zentrale Argument der
Republikaner ist das Geld was im Moment
an die Ukraine geht das brauchen wir
selber für uns ich finde Europa ich weiß
ja würde gerne Herr melnick den sie
vorhin zitiert haben den Botschafter
fragen was er denn meint mit der
diplomatischen Offensive im Unterschied
zu gutschka denke ich muss ausprobiert
werden ein Waffenstillstand mit
Verhandlungen wobei völlig klar ist
damit das kein Missverständnis hier
wieder erzeugt dass die Forderung die
Wiederherstellung der Ukraine in ihren
international auch von Russland mehrfach
anerkannten Grenzen muss auf dem Tisch
Blei ben und dann muss man drüber reden
über
einig die muss Tisch darf nicht schon
vorher aufgegeben werden etwa aus
Washington und dann werden auch alle
europäischen Staaten natürlich
nachbotzeln und da muss man reden über
punkte die schon am 29 März 22 von der
ukrainischen Seite auf den Tisch gelegt
wurden ich will sie jetzt nicht alle
wiederholen die sind relevant zweitens
muss man reden über die Frage
Wiederherstellung von sicherheitspakten
von
abrüstungsrüstungskontrollpakten die
alle mal bestanden leider über wegend
von amerikanischer Seite zunächst
gekündigt wurde zum Teil dann auch von
Putin und drittens sag ganz klar muss in
einem
verhandlungspaket auch irgendetwas drin
sein für Putin nicht eine territoriale
Konzession aber z. Sicherheitsgarantie
Sicherheitsgarantien über die der
außenpolitische Chefberater von Scholz
ja schon mal gesprochen hat in dem
Interview mit der F also das bestimmte
Waffensysteme z.B nicht in der Ukraine
stationiert werden da ließen sich noch
andere Beispiele denken so müsste
endlich mal eriert werden vielleicht
zunächst mal in hochgeheimen Sondierung
bleiben wir dabei bei bei was man
Zugeständnisse an Putin der muss Gesicht
warahren verstehe ich so verstehe ich
sie da wier nicht Gesichtswahrung es
gibt auch trotz dieses fürchterlichen
durch nicht zurechtfertigen
Angriffskrieges legitime
Sicherheitsinteressen des Verlierers des
Kalten Krieges und die muss man
irgendwie mit anerkennen das ist keine
territoriale
Konzession wenn man jetzt einen
waffenstehstand vereinbaren würde dann
hieße das ja dass Russland sich
festsetzt an der jetzigen Frontlinie die
1200 km lang ist das würde bedeuten dass
die Ukraine sich natürlich in einem
permanenten Verteidigungszustand weiter
befinden würde weil sie ja überhaupt
kein zutrauen haben kann dass nicht wenn
die Situation günstig erscheint Russland
wieder zuschlägt also also machen Sie
doch die Vertreibung Russlands aus
diesen Stellungen zur Vorbedingung für
den Verhandlungsbeginn genauso wie
Regierung Vertreibung ein gewagtes Wort
für einen Besetzer
ich glaube dass das sollte man etwas
anders semantisch benutzen aber im Osten
sehe ich in der Tat keine großen
Möglichkeiten für die Ukraine terr
zurück zu erobern ich glaube es war auch
ein Fehler im letzten Herbst dass man
sich da verkämpft hat bei bachmut man
hätte die Kräfte auf den Süden
konzentrieren müssen aber es nicht
hinnehmbar für die Ukraine dass diese
Landbrücke zur Krim besteht und russ da
also täglich hin und her fahren kann mit
schwerem militärischem Gerät und dieses
Territorium diese Achse und damit auch
die den Zugang zu den Häfen kontrolliert
blockiert für die Ukraine nur es wird
sicher irgendwann Verhandlungen geben
müssen wenn man das jetzt macht wäre es
eine
Kapitulation für die Ukraine Frau M Ihr
Widerspruch zu hern zumach also wieb
gibt es irgendeine Möglichkeit man sagt
man muss ein Teil der Territorien
aufgeben ist das um dann diesen Krieg zu
behenden beenden wäre ist das überhaupt
ein Punkt der denkbar ist in der Ukraine
das habe ich nicht gesagt ne nur um es
noch mal klar zu machen weil sie auf
mich bezogen haben ich habe das nicht
gesagt ich habe es ausdrücklich als das
schlechteste denkbare Ergebnis dieses
Krieges beschrieben und ich möchte
immer Position gesetzt werden ich wäre
für territoriale Konzession aber dann W
sie sagen es muss auf dem Tisch bleiben
die Forderungen das die
Wiederherstellung der Ukraine in ihren
international anerkannten Grenzen äh die
muss auf dem Tisch bleiben und darf
nicht aufgegeben werden die weder von
der Regierung beidens was ich befürchte
und dann würden alle europäischen
Regierungen auch die unseren natürlich
na aber sie sagen es soll trotzdem
irgendwie eine Richtung in zu Bewegung
auf Putin geben die habe ich doch klar
benannt ich habe gesagt es müssen auch
Sicherheitsgarantien die auch Russland
legitim auch ökonomische können wir
drüber reden wenn es denn zu einem
EU-Beitritt kommt äh der Ukraine die
müssen auch mit in so einem Paket drin
sein Okay na ja sie haben
Waffenstillstand angesprochen und sie
haben Waffenstillstand angesprochen es
gab bereits einen und diesen hat
Russland nur dafür genutzt um sich
aufzurüsten welchen meinen sie welchen
na ja nach Minsk 1 wurde versucht mit
zwei wurde versucht und es es gibt keine
sogar Hoffnung dass Russland sich anders
jetzt verhalten wird das eine mein
erster Punkt der zweite Punkte das Ziel
das militäris Ziel von Putin war die
Existenz der Ukraine zu vernichten ja es
sprach von imaginären Nazis die irgendwo
in KI sitzen und und und
tifizierung der Ukraine da er brauchen
wir nicht um diese Territorien zu
sprechen weil er hat nie Interesse
gezeigt ach ich brauche herson ich
brauche saorisia er hat davon gar nicht
gesprochen das heißt da wo die Front
jetzt verläuft das ist einfach aktueller
Zustand des Krieges das bedeutet auch
dass die versuchen weiterhin Kiev zu zu
erobern das war vor kurzem auch sehr
öffentlich über von Dmitri medwedev auch
kommuniziert wir brauchen Kiev wir
brauchen auch andere altrussische
sozusagen Territorien und so weiter
daher sehe ich gar keine Hoffnung bei
Putin
dass er verhandlungsbereit wäre und zu
dem Gewinn wir haben auch am Anfang
darüber gesprochen für die Ukraine was
bedeutet ein Gewinn es geht auch nicht
so sehr um die Territorien klar man man
möchte die Territorien wiederherstellen
und so weiter es geht um die Sicherung
der Existenz dass man mit so einem
Nachbar leben kann und das nicht unsere
Generation und die Generation unserer
Kinder dann ständig an die Front muss
und das muss gesichert werden das kann
nur über die Militär gesichert werden
also wä es doch wichtiger das heißt aber
z.B Sicherheitsgarantien verlässliche
die auch in dem ukrainischen
Regierungsvorschlag in Ankara am 29 März
22 sehr klar definiert auf dem
tischlagen als Vorschlag mit den Ländern
auch die diese Sicherheitsgarantien
geben sollen darunter unter anderem auch
Deutschland auch die USA ja da bin ich
voll ihrer Meinung aber das ist doch was
anderes als wenn man der Illusion nach
wie vor folgt dass die Ukraine diesen
aktuellen Krieg in dem Russland leider
die
eskalationssdominanz hat wie man in der
derzeit in brutalen Beschießung ziviler
Ziele wiedersieht dass die Ukraine
dieses militärisch für sich gewinnen
könnte und wenn das Ziel nicht ist die
Rückeroberung wie sie sagen dann muss
das endlich mal auch von einer
westuropäischen Regierung klar gesagt
werden bisher ist das das offiziell
deklarierte Ziel an dem übrigens die
vier beratungsverhandlungen in
Kopenhagen in Riad in Davos und in
valalletta alle gescheitert sind weil
alle Länder des Südens gesagt haben die
Rückeroberung zur Vorbedingung für
Verhandlungen zu machen das geht nicht
deswegen ist selenski mit diesem Plan
bei allen Ländern des Südens auf
Ablehung also die die Haltung äh der
europäischen Staaten ist äh nicht dass
die Rück Ukraine alles zurück erobern
muss bevor man verhandeln kann sondern
die Haltung ist dass die Ukraine darüber
entscheidet wie Sie vorgehen will und
das ist ich kann das ich halte das für
richtig wir können ja nicht einfach der
Ukraine hier den Stecker ziehen unsere
Soldaten sterben nicht dafür es ist
tatsächlich so dass den Blutzoll einzig
und allein die Ukrainer bezahlen so
schlimmer und deswegen ist es eine
Entscheidung der ukrainischen Regierung
nur diese Entscheidung ist ja nicht
unabhängig von uns wenn wir unsere
Unterstützung aufgeben zwingen wir sie
ja
an
in eine Kapitulation das darf meiner
Meinung nach nicht passieren und es gibt
noch einen Punkt wir sind da auch nicht
einfach nur Zuschauer wir haben ja in
den letzten Wochen gehört dass es alle
möglichen Prognosen gibt wann Russland
auch ein natostaat angreifen könnte und
dann hören wir immer drei bis fün Jahre
bis Jahre haben wir noch Zeit um uns
darauf vorzubereiten worin also
eingeschlossen ist dass wir nicht
vorbereitet sind aber an dem Tag wo
dieser Konflikt eingefroren wird und es
einen Waffenstillstand gäbe den man der
Ukraine aufzwingen würde an dem Tag
beginnt die russische Aufrüstung und
dann beginnt die Uhr zu ticken das
müssen wir uns klar machen wir sind hier
nicht nur Zuschauer sondern wir haben
ein eminentes Interesse daran dass
Russland weiterhin militärisch
geschwächt wird und deswegen muss
Deutschland und Europa die müssen sich
selber handeln und selber entscheiden
und nicht immer nach Amerika gucken weil
in die Antwort die man von Amerika
braucht wird man nicht kriegen egal ob
beiden bleibt und wenn Trump kommt
bestimmt nicht und das ist das Problem
ist dass Europa guckt immer noch auf
Amerika was macht Amerika was sagt der
Präsident von Amerika über Ukraine oder
über diesen Konflikt oder den Konflikt
und das ist wirklich und deswegen wir
ist auch eine Müdigkeit in Amerika über
die Unterstützung von Europa und NATO
und so weiter weil die die Amer
Amerikaner sagen irgendwann muss Europa
das auch wirklich selber im Griff
kriegen die Verteidigung auf wen schauen
die USA da besonders also Scholz fährt
ja jetzt nächste Woche nach Washington
ist das ist für Deutschland die zentrale
ma war Merkel immer mehr interessant
Frau Merkel war immer mehr interessant
für die amerikane die sind ja immer auf
Persönlichkeiten also das ist wo die
hingucken ich würde sagen ja also Scholz
ist nicht unbeding einer wo sie wo sie
hingucken macron ist mehr interessant
für Amerikaner und ich rede jetzt mehr
über Wähler und Wähler sind dieses Jahr
sehr wichtig für die amerikanische
Regierung also aber ja ich ich meine man
hofft dass irgendwas ja aus dieser diese
Rede kommt zwischen Scholz und die
beiden Regierungen
aber werden sehen okay werden wir sehen
aber das ist wichtig dass dass Europa
sich da eben anders aufstellt Frau melni
wie sehr haben sie den Eindruck dass da
sich in ja dass die Europäer genauso gut
noch unterstützen wie die Amerikaner und
wie schaut man aus der Ukraine auf die
USA
ich glaube man ist sehr vorsichtig auch
und es gibt mitblick auf die USA und man
möchte gar ke auf gar keine Spekulation
eingehen aber man weiß ja ganz genau wir
leben in demokratischen Staaten und die
öffentlicher Meinung spielt eine große
Rolle und das wird auch ein Einfluss auf
die Politik nehmen und deswegen ist auch
meine These die Öffentlichkeit wird und
ist so eine Zielscheibe der russischen
Propaganda und Desinformation geworden
und wir sollen uns mehr Gedanken darüber
machen wie wir ein Widerstand dazu
leisten können und äh ich wollte nur
sagen weil wir haben sehr viel über
gegen Offensive gesprochen ich finde das
ein bisschen zynisch dass man so lange
von der Ukraine erwartet hat dass jetzt
kommt eine schöne Gegenoffensive ohne
vorher sogar Panzer zu liefern ohne
militärische Flugzeuge zu liefern man
hat einfach die Menschen dahin geschickt
und jetzt macht wir de eine schöne
Gegenoffensive glau muss mus
sindief die wurden geliefert aber immer
immer später später und das ich glaube
man muss wirklich darüber reden warum
dieser Zeitpunkt immer verschoben wird
warum das nicht rechtzeitig gemacht wird
und dann wurden sie wenn sie geliefert
wurden immer als gamechanger tituliert
was in keinem Fall zugetroffen hat und
jetzt passiert das wieder also ich habe
die Illusion nie gehabt es tut mir
wirklich Leid von daher kann ich mir den
Schuh auch nicht anziehen sie haben
natürlich in der Beschreibung da haben
Sie Recht nur das müssen s ein bisschen
schon zieren da aber ohne die
militärische Hilfe wäre die Ukraine
überrannt worden ich ich bin überhaupt
nicht gegen die Waffenlieferung zum
Anfang gewesen Teile das auch würde
differenzieren die schlimme Rhetorik von
Putin die sie zuitiert haben die durch
nichts zu rechtfertigen ist ist das eine
ob es tatsächlich weiter darum geht die
ganze Ukraine zu erobern habe ich meine
Zweifel ob er sich nicht
zufriedenstellen würde mit dem ganzen
donbas und so und der Krim was es nicht
besser macht aber gut
dass die militärische Unterstützung am
Anfang dazu gedient hat zu verhindern
dass Kiev in drei Tagen gefallen ist
sehe ich ganz genauso nur die dauernde
Fortsetzung ohne ein klares Ziel und
auch im Konsens der westlichen Staaten
hat uns in die Situation gebracht in der
wir heute sind und ich bleibe bei der
Illusion vor allem
herrch die die wenn sie sagen wir müssen
die ukrainische Regierung entscheidet
und wir können nicht den Stecker ziehen
ja aber wir unterstützen eine
ukrainische Regierung deren offiziell
deklarierte Ziele die sind die ich
zitiert habe also das ist doch se also
es gibt ja eine es gibt ja eine Debatte
in Kiev darüber diese Debatte wird über
zwei Fragen geführt das eine ist ob man
in eine defensive
kriegshaltung übergeht aktive
Verteidigung heißt das
das ist etwas was der operbefehlshaber
saluschni offenbar befürwortet selenski
scheint das etwas anders zu sehen da
gibt es einen Konflikt der auch ein
Konflikt äh zwischen nicht nur zwei
zwischen zwei Persönlichkeiten äh ist
sondern möglicherweise auch um die
Zukunft äh des des
Präsidentenamtes und
es gibt einen Konflikt
über die Zahl der Männer die man bereit
ist zu rekrutieren was ja in der Tat
eine sehr gravierende Entscheidung ist
selenski hat ungefähr 500 die Zahl
500.000
genannt und das sind finde ich äh in ein
wir sagen immer die Ukraine ist ein wir
verlangen dass es ein demokratischer
Staat ist solche Dinge müssen
demokratisch ausgehandelt werden und wir
müssen dem Land die Optionen verschaffen
aber die Entscheidung auch über den
blutsul kann einzig und allein die
Ukraine treffen wie viel Unruhe ist das
gerade bevor wir zu ihren Anrufen kommen
Frau Mel vielleicht noch kurz die die
diese Auseinandersetzung auch gerade
zwischen saluschnin und selenski also
den Militärchef viele vernehmen das
einfach aus den Medien man sieht es gibt
Diskrepanzen aber ehrlich gesagt
ich glaube da gibt es auch sehr viele
Spekulationen sogar die diejenigen die
da vertraut sind wissen nicht so ganz
genau was da abläuft aber es wird
diskutiert aber mit Blick auf die
Mobilisierung das ist ich finde das ist
ganz normaler Prozess weil die Ukraine
wurde überrannt sozusagen das ist okay
dass man heute sich Gedanken macht wie
mobilisiert man die Menschen und dass
die Menschen die zwei Jahre jetzt an der
Front sind die brauchen jetzt sozusagen
Urlaub und das ist völlig okay dass
darüber auch in der Ukraine gesprochen
ja das ist auch völlig okay
aber die Zuschauer Z es ist doch ein
objektives Problem was auch viele
vorausgesagt haben dass die numerische
Überlegenheit Russlands
kaum auszugleichen ist und jetzt sind
wir an dem Punkt dass 900.000 Männer im
werfähigen Alter im Ausland sind was
nicht zu kritisieren ganz gerne die die
Zuhörer die Zuhörer und Hörerin Beil
WDR5 und unsere Zuschauer hier beim
frühchop Phöenix würde ich ganz gerne zu
Wort kommen lassen ich begrüße Harald
kreitling aus zevenen guten Tag guten
Tag in die Runde wie sicher die Frage
wird mir zu selten gestellt ist Putin
auf seinem Thron die Oligarchen haben
vor dem Angriff sehr gern im dekadenten
den Untergang geweiten Westen gelebt
unzufriedenht ist hier doch auf jeden
Fall verbreitet ebenfalls von China wenn
die Russland nicht offen kritisieren ist
das
normal sage ich jetzt mal die sind aber
auch unzufrieden wie die Frage gebe ich
denn gerne weiter an Frau Nelson und
hern gutschka wie sie die Situation
sehen die Sicherheit Putins okay ja
vielen Dank Herr kitling ich schleör wie
sicher Putin auf sein Tron sozusagen die
Oligarchen haben ja sehr gerne im Westen
gelebt also wie groß ist eine Chance
dass sich so sozusagen auch was von
innen verändert in Russland wir hatten
ja diese Frage uns gestellt als es zu
der Wagner Revolte kam und in der Tat
gab es 24 Stunden in denen wir nicht
sicher waren ob diese Wagner Söldner es
schaffen würden nach Moskau zu
marschieren ob sie vielleicht vom
Geheimdienst Unterstützung bekommen ob
die Armee sich raushält und das wäre das
Ende von Putin gewesen aber er hat sich
behauptet und deswegen müssen wir im
Moment jedenfalls
unterstellen dass er weiterhin die
Kontrolle ausübt über alle wichtigen
Machtfaktoren er hat es geschafft die
gesamte Opposition zu unterdrücken er
wird jetzt wieder eine
scheinpräsidentenwahl abhalten und so
sehr wir uns das
wünschen dass es eine Zeit nach Putin
gibt im Moment gibt es aus me er sich
keine Perspektive dafür und die Frage
über Amerika jetzt ne das ging jetzt
darum um die um Putin also die Frage ist
halt einfach gibt's noch eine
Möglichkeit sozusagen oder wie wie wird
es aus Amerika gesehen wie sehr sieht
man Putin als derjenigen der da auch
fest im Sat oh ja also man sieht und
Trump hat ja auch gesagt wie er also
puen neidet und wir wie viel Respekt er
hat für die Kontrolle die er hat und das
möchte ja gerne an Amerika selber haben
also ja da also ich glaube da ist keiner
der sagt oh Putin kommt jetzt weg das
sehe ich nicht okay dazu passt
vielleicht die Frage von Horst Schulze
aus Springe Deister schönen guten Tag
Herr Schulze schön guten Tag auch bitte
Ihre Frage ich habe was ich nicht
verstehe dass
Russland erstmal das größte Land der
Welt ist und diese kleine Ukraine noch
haben will aber was ich nicht richtig
verstehe warum darf Deutschland z.B
keine Waffen liefern die nach Russland
reinreichen der Putin macht die Ukraine
total kaputt und die können sich nicht
weren dürfen nur innerhalb der Ukraine
die Waffen nutzen und das finde ich
unfair mh aber dafür gibt's ein klaren
Grund Herr gutschka der also Sie haben
recht es gibt das Recht zur
Selbstverteidigung und zudem gehört auch
dass man sich nicht nur auf seinem
eigenen Territorium verteidigen darf
allerdings hat die NATO zu Kriegsbeginn
eine klare Linie festgelegt und das
heißt dass S sich selbst als Allianz
nicht in diesen Krieg hineinziehen
lassen will und das bedeutet dass man
das
eskalationspotential versucht zu
begrenzen alle natostaaten nicht nur
Deutschland auch das Vereinigte
Königreich verfolgen diese Politik
Angriffe mit unseren Waffen nur gegen
Besatzungstruppen nicht auf russischem
Territorium das ist in der Tat eine
Begrenzung äh und es ist für die Ukraine
auch nicht einfach allerdings hat die
Ukraine wie wir ja gerade sehen mm in
den letzten Wochen
Möglichkeiten gefunden Russland sehr
gezielt anzugreifen gerade in stankt
petersburg das sind ja Angriffe mit
denen wir gar nicht gerechnet haben und
die Russland auch schon bemerkenswerten
Schaden zugefügt haben also vielleicht
gibt es hier auch eine Arbeitsteilung
ohne dass man eskalieren muss aber das
ist auch immer ein Grund warum Scholz
zögerlich ist den Taurus zu aber ich
würde gern dazu was sagen ich halte das
für eine absolute chemäre diese
trendnlinie zu glauben man ist erst an
im Krieg beteiligt wenn man Waffen
liefert die auch das Territorium des
Angreifers angreifen erreichen konnen
das das ist eine Fiktion vor allem ist
doch die Frage ob die NATO nun im Krieg
ist vor allem eine im Kopf von Herrn
Putin und seiner Willkür unterlegt der
hat schon nach den ersten
wirtschaftssanktion in den ersten
Kriegswochen gesagt die NATO ist jetzt
im Krieg mit uns also ich halte diese
drinlinie für künstlich aber das
entscheiden ist er hat sie nicht
angegriffen er hat nicht versucht
zurückzuschlagen
und z.B auf Gebiet
Rüstungs die Grenzlinie ist willkürlich
die funktioniert okay wir kommen mal zum
weil wir haben natürlich begrenzte Zeit
deshalb komme ich zum nächsten Anrufer
damit sie auch zu Wort kommen detle
Kröger aus Leipzig bitttechön ja guten
Tag mein Name ist Krüger und zwar
erstmal guten Tag an alle Tag gut mir g
weit zurück ein Sprichwort man soll den
russischen beren Nichten das haben wir
jetzt und das hat die NATO mit ihren
Verlagerungen gemacht
und wieesagt wir müssen sofort wirklich
sofort an den Verhandlungstisch da
müssen wirklich sich die Leute
zusammenreisen wenn Frau Le Pen jetzt
auf den Stuhl steigt Hermer weg ist dann
gehen wir hier komplett
wassersaufen so sieht's mal aus und
möchte ich noch sagen der zumach soll
ich mal ein bisschen zurückhalten und
den Leuten nicht immer über den Mund
fahren das ist meine Meinung ja gut ist
ja wichtig dass wir hier respektvoll
miteinander umgehen also das jetzt
kurze Kritik aber wie schafft man es an
den Verhandlungstisch zu kommen
vielleicht ganz kurz ähm das ist da was
Sie da sagen äh das hört man oft es
stimmt aber so einfach
nicht es war nicht so dass die
NATO hier
Russland überrollt hat und diesen
Angriff auf die Ukraine irgendwie
provoziert hätte äh sondern hier ist ein
eklatanter Bruch des Völkerrechts
geschehen durch Russland der die die
gesamte Ordnung Nachkriegsordnung
Europas in Frage gestellt hat die
natoosterweiterung dem Gegenüber das
waren freie Entscheidungen freier
Staaten die das Recht zur
Bündnisfreiheit haben NATO hat Russland
nicht militärisch bedroht
und deswegen sollten wir das Bild gerade
rücken es war nicht der russische Bär
den wir geärgert haben sondern es der
russische Bär der auf sehr brutale Art
und Weise mörderische Art und Weise in
die Ukraine eingefallen ist und wenn wir
dem jetzt nicht Einheit Gebieten
riskieren wir dass er sein Hunger noch
größer wird und er sich auch andere
Brocken auf dieser Landkarte vorknüpft
also da sie mich direkt angegriffen
haben würde ich gerne sagen ich Teile
her gutschers Bewertung des
Angriffskrieges völlig ich sage
allerdings die natoosterweiterung die
ich für ein historischen Fehler von
Anfang ang gehalten habe statt
gemeinsames Haus Europa gehört zu einer
vor Geschichte nicht als Rechtfertigung
und wenn wir ein Interesse haben und
haben müssen als Europäer irgendwann
wieder mit Russland zumindest irgendwie
gedeilig nebeneinander zu leben dann
müssen wir auch an diese Vorgeschichte
ran und versuchen vielleicht einiges zu
korrigieren da habe ich eine ganz andere
Meinung mit Blick auf die Vorgeschichte
die NATO das ist einfach künstlicher
narrativ der Russland geschaffen hat und
wir handeln immer aus Angst wer hat
gesagt dass das ein B ist ja weil
Russland da so kommuniziert weil
Russland einfach nach außen zeigt wir
sind so so gut aufgestellt wer hat das
gesagt und ich glaube dieser Angst
müssen wir ablegen und diese Angst
beeinflusst auch unsere Handlungen ja
und nämlich das ist diese Desinformation
mit der wir zu tun haben daher ja kommen
wir zum nächsten Anrufer Andreas
haukwitz aus Hachenburg schönen guten
Tag Herr haukwitz ja schönen guten Tag
gruß an
alle würde mal passieren erstmal ganz
kurz ich glaube die Ukraine wird das
letztenes ohnehin für sich entscheiden
bis jetzt ist es noch keinem Land
gelungen ein anderes ewig zu besetzen
schaue Vietnam an aber meine Frage ist
wenn ich habe mal gehört dass so eine
wirtschaftliche Hilfe z.B wenn die
Amerikaner da 100 Milliarden zuagen dass
80 Milliarden also 80% ungefähr davon im
Land bleibt nun frage ich mich ob der
beiden oder der Trump sich überhaupt
trauen würden diese Hilfe zu kürzen das
bedeutet ja dass sie ihre eigene
Wirtschaft kürzen okay aber meine Frage
ist triff das eigentlich auch für Europa
zu das wäre meine Frage okay also wie
wichtig ist die militärische Hilfe als
sozusagen auch als Wirtschaftshilfe aber
von vielleicht wollen Sie da auch kurz
drauf eingehen also wenn man jetzt sagt
die USA geben die Hilfe nicht mehr
schneiden Sie sich damit sozusagen auch
ins eigene Fleisch schneiden die sich
ins eigene Fleisch ja also das das das
tun die aber das Problem ist wie gesagt
es ist ein Wahljahr in Amerika
präsidentchwal ja und
Außenpolitik bringt nichts für die
Kandidaten und da ist ein Krieg jetzt
zur Zeit also ein Krieg da sind mehrere
Kriege zur Zeit wo Amerika also
verbunden ist und deswegen ja würden
sich würden die Kandidaten sich lieber
selber im Fleisch schneiden
als die Wahl zu verlieren und das ist
nur mal die Realität also in Amerika ist
zur Zeit ein richtiger Wahlkampf und
beiden also das ist nicht gesagt dass er
gewennt also ist ja wobei die Zahlen des
Fragestellers natürlich nicht ganz stimm
ist es richtig bei der Militärhilfe
gehen über 80% der bewilligten Gelder an
die amerikanische Rüstungsindustrie die
dann die Waffen liefert aber die USA
haben ja auch eine zweistölige Summe von
Wirtschaftshilfe gegeben die geht eben
schon direkt an die Ukraine ne woll
sagen Differenzierung des Fragesteller
äh
ja genau bei den Europäern ist es
natürlich genauso ähm das was wir der
Ukraine liefern kommt von europäischen
rüstungsherstellern soweit sie liefern
können sonst kommt aus Amerika dann geht
das Geld nach Amerika aber wir kaufen ja
nicht ukrainische Güter die gibt es
einfach nicht in hinreichender Zahl so m
allerdings das heißt das man sieht an
den gestiegenen äh
rüstungsaktien äh dass da erhebliche
Gewinne gemacht werden allerdings
liefern wir im Moment der Ukraine Waffen
die wir selbst für die Bundeswehr nicht
haben wie z.B das Iris t
Raketenabwehrsystem und deswegen muss
man auch hier sagen also ist es nicht so
dass dass wir hier egoistisch handeln
den Aufschwung für die Rüstungsindustrie
würde es auch geben wenn wir überhaupt
die Bundeswehr erstmal wieder in die
Lage versetzen würden wirklich
bündnisverteidigung zu machen mhm ganz
kurze letzte Frage noch Frank Knut aus
Berlin aber bitte kurz her kN ja ganz
kurz an die Amerikanerin können die
Amerikaner sich das überhaupt erlauben
sich da zurückzuziehen weil das ist eine
Blaupause für China und China hat ein
Griff nach Taiwan und Taiwan mit ein
chipsstelle ist für alle vor allem für
Amerika wichtig und da besteht doch die
Gefahr dass Amerika mit China in
Konfrontation FT und das wollen sie doch
bestimmt auch nicht ja also das wollen
wir nicht aber da achten Sie drauf also
sie die sehen ich ich sehe nicht ich
sehe das nicht so dass wenn die also
Ukrain nicht helfen dass dann das andere
Länder also dass China davon äh also
irgendin Gewinn kriegt aber das das
Problem wie gesagt ich gehe immer zurück
wieder auf auf die Wahl und das ist
zurzeit Nummer eins für Biden für Trump
für alle in Amerika und
die also die Ukraine ist nicht ein
positives Gewinn für beiden und was
Trump Dara raus kriegt ist wenn er sagt
wir wollen nichts mehr mit Ukraine zu
tun haben oder wir also in 24 Stunden
ist der Krieg vorbei er braucht gar
nicht erklären wie das macht das ist was
amerikanische Wähler hören möchten oder
wenigstens die Mehrheit von Republikaner
und eine Größe also großes Teil von die
Demokraten wobei es in Washington in den
vielen außenpolitischen Denkfabriken
durchaus Stimmen gibt die sagen wir
haben strategisches Dilemma brauchen wir
nicht eigentlich Russland mittel und
langfristig doch als Bündnispartner
gegen gegenüber unseren
Hauptkonkurrenten China diese Debatte
gibt's in Washington auch die führen wir
dann ein anderer Stelle in diesem
internationalen frü en vielen Dank für
ihre Beiträge hier Herr gutchka Frau
Melnik Frau Nelson und Herr zumach
vielen dank ihnen fürs zuschauen das war
der internationale Frühschoppen an
diesem Sonntag nächsten Sonntag sind wir
wieder für Sie da bis dahin schönen
Sonntag ihnen noch aus Köln bis
[Musik]
dann begrüße Sie sehr herzlich vor der
Brandenburg Staatskanzlei in Potzdam wir
werden hier gleich den
Ministerpräsidenten des Landes Dietmar
wge treffen er ist seit 10 Jahren im Amt
und Brandenburg gehört zu einer der
parteipolitischen traditionshochburgen
kann man sagen noch denn seit 19